[Musik]
umstritten ist auch das vorgehen von
bodo ramelow thüringen der villa die
korona maßnahmen aufheben argumentiert
es gibt ja noch rund 250 infizierte in
thüringen bei ihnen mecklenburg
vorpommern sind es noch weniger sollte
frau schwesig das dann auch machen in
ihrem bundesland also einerseits ist es
so dass ich schon sagen muss gerade ich
als jemand der auch in den
zurückliegenden wochen immer wieder auch
für lockerungen geworben hat gerade auch
auf dem hintergrund der grundrechte kann
natürlich schon verstehen dass man jetzt
sagt man will sich auf den weg machen um
maßnahmen zurückzunehmen in der art und
weise die bodo ramelow es jetzt gemacht
hat finde ich es allerdings nicht
richtig vor allem dieser alleingang der
dort praktiziert wird ist natürlich wir
haben doch die erwartung und das sehen
auch die menschen der für ein
koordiniertes vorgehen haben wollen dass
bodo ramelow sich jetzt entscheidet an
seiner eigenen landesregierung vorbei an
allen ministerpräsidenten vorbei einen
eigenen profilierungs vorschlag zu
machen ist erst mal vielleicht nicht
inhalt der politischen fairness und
zweitens müssen wir auch sagen ich finde
es wichtig dass wir
wissenschaftsbasierte jetzt analysieren
heute gibt es die notwendigen öffnungs
perspektiven für den tourismus zum
beispiel in mecklenburg vorpommern ich
habe mich sehr dafür eingesetzt dass wir
dort zu lockerungen kommen ich finde
jetzt sollten wir aber auch erstmal
analysieren was diese lockerungen dann
für das infektionsgeschehen bedeuten es
ist ganz wichtig dass wir das
infektionsgeschehen gut in den griff
bekommen haben gerade auch in
mecklenburg vorpommern durch harte
maßnahmen aber wir müssen es doch jetzt
auch schaffen dass wir nicht zu früh den
schritt der großen lockerung gehen und
deswegen würde ich dazu raten den weg
hin zu dem ausstieg aus dem lockt dann
ja auf jeden fall aber
wissenschaftsbasierte analysieren was
die verschiedenen lockerungsschritte
bringen und jetzt nicht sich pauschal
festlegen das hat man
wissenschaftsbasierte guckt sich genau
die zahlen an den thüringen und er sagt
da wo die zahlen hoch gehen da mache ich
strengere regeln und da wo die zahl
niedrig sind da locker ich dagegen gibt
es keine kennen sie in mecklenburg
vorpommern jemanden der korona hatte man
mit ich kenne im moment niemanden ich
kenne aber viele die korona hatten und
ich kenne in mecklenburg vorpommern
menschen die wegen corona an der
beatmungsmaschine waren ich kenne viele
tolle programm daheim ein läufer haben
loriots gefasst und ich finde und
trotzdem nicht
das gefährliche dass wir so jetzt reden
wir kennen in unserem umfeld niemanden
der korona hat dadurch ist das virus
aber kein stück ungefährlicher geworden
sondern die wahrscheinlichkeit sich bei
20 menschen im land anzustecken ist
wesentlich geringer als sich bei 2.000
natürlich und deswegen sollen diese
maßnahmen müssen gelockert werden und
ich erwarte auch das ist eine weitere
welle oder einen weiteren schritt an
lockerungen gibt dass es richtig und
notwendig aber in der pauschalität
sozusagen von null und eins zu sagen ja
jetzt fallen alle staatlichen verbote
alle gebote das halte ich nicht für
richtig sondern wir müssen gestuft
vorgehen so wie wir in mecklenburg
vorpommern jetzt gesagt haben ab heute
gibt es wieder den tourismus auch
außerhalb des landes das finde ich gut
und richtig aber ich finde wir sollten
dann auch mal das kann man erst
zeitversetzt im infektionsgeschehen
ablesen dann jetzt auch noch mal zwei
wochen drei wochen mal bewerten was
heißt das wir entwickelt sich das und
wenn es dann weitere möglichkeiten für
lockerungen gibt bin ich der erste der
dafür ist weiter zu lockern aber in der
pauschalität jetzt alle maßnahmen fallen
zu lassen halte ich für fein ein letztes
zu thüringen was machen sie wenn das
funktioniert das haben wir gerade mit
herrn klingen weil auch schon versucht
herauszufinden was machen sie wenn das
funktioniert dann freuen müssen sie zwar
sagen sie freuen sich aber
möglicherweise denken sie hintenrum
mensch das zeigt dass wir übertrieben
gehandelt haben dass wir nicht auf dem
richtigen pfad waren dann wissen sie bei
corona geht es mir also wirklich nicht
um dieses politische klein-klein es geht
darum dass wir es doch schaffen müssen
eine gesamt vernünftige lösung
hinzubekommen das infektionsgeschehen in
den griff zu bekommen
wenn es in thüringen funktioniert dann
werden alle sagen ja was war das für ein
genialer schachzug aber ich kann nur
sagen ich wäre zu vorsichtig gegenüber
einem land um es hier zu einem
versuchsfeld zu machen
und deswegen halte ich diese maßnahmen
die bodo ramelow vorgeschlagen hat für
überzogen etwas so viele eltern
beschäftigt der normalen schulunterricht
kann es den erst wieder geben wenn es
einen impfstoff gibt wir manche
argumentiert haben oder kann man auf die
abstandsregeln dann auch verzichten zum
beispiel zum neuen schuljahr
ich glaube da müssen wir jetzt wirklich
sehen dass gerade für schule und kita
noch mehr öffnungs und normalisierung
perspektiven kommen das ist glaube ich
sehr wichtig da muss man verschiedene
abhebungen sehen wir haben zum beispiel
in meinem heimatbundesland in
mecklenburg vorpommern in neustrelitz ja
ein projekt wo zb durch unter
stützung eines pharmaunternehmens aus
rostock corona tests gemacht werden bei
allen schülern und diejenigen die dann
positiv getestet sind gehen wieder in
die normalisierung der klassengröße das
ist eine möglichkeit die ich mir
vorstellen kann und ist es wichtig dass
hier genau hier genau die position die
die immunisiert sind sozusagen die
positiv also in der korona negativ
getestet sind so ist die aussage richtig
also die die korona negativ sind was
bisher alle schüler dort waren die
finden dann ein weg weiter zur
normalisierung das ist noch eine
freiwillige option aber ich finde mit
solchen innovativen konzepten kann man
eigentlich gut vorankommen das finde ich
richtig und notwendig weil gerade im
bereich der schule müssen wir schon
sehen dass jetzt gerade durch die
aktuelle situation wir natürlich in
einen großen spalt laufen zwischen denen
die zuhause gute bildung gute
voraussetzungen haben und denjenigen wo
es nicht so ist und das macht mir schon
große sorgen und deswegen sollten wir
schauen dass es im bereich der schule
auch wie der normalisierung geben kann
wie ist das bei ihnen im landkreis es
ist jetzt auch nicht einer der
landkreise mit der dichtesten oder
höchsten bevölkerung ist trotzdem ein
sehr schöner wahlkreis i ist das bei
ihrem wochenendes wenn jetzt gutes
wetter war oder am vatertag hält man
sich da ganz strikt an die regeln oder
macht man das nur wenn der am tor vorbei
guckt und in den vorgarten guckt wie wie
ist das denn mit beschreiben sie mal den
normalen umgang dort im supermarkt oder
im vorgarten
also ich habe den eindruck die menschen
in mecklenburg vorpommern gehen sehr
verantwortungsvoll mit der situation um
gleichzeitig ist es jetzt so dass wir
natürlich eine situation haben dass das
infektionsgeschehen gut im griff ist
aber auch wir halten uns dort auch im
ländlichen raum an die regeln und das
ist auch wenn es diese ich wollte auf
was anderes hinaus möglicherweise sind
die im vorgarten im moment mit mehr
menschen unterwegs als sie dann in der
schule sitzen dürfen beziehungsweise da
entsteht eine erhebliche differenz
deswegen die frage noch mal die hand von
bayern gestellt hat wann ist das so wann
wann ist es so dass man so wie man sich
im vorgarten verhält sich auch wieder in
der schule verhalten darf ja also ich
finde es wir müssen sehen gerade beim
bereich schule und kita haben wir auch
die überlagerung natürlich jetzt durch
mehrere gerichtsentscheidungen in den
letzten wochen gehabt dass die gesagt
haben die normale sie
kann nicht so schnell gehen da muss erst
mal geschaut werden wie entwickelt sich
das infektionsgeschehen da muss auch auf
sicherheit entsprechend geachtet werden
deswegen müssen wir dort noch einige
schritte mehr vornehmen aber ich habe ja
deutlich gemacht ich wünsche mir dass
wir mit innovativen konzepten die korona
tests mit verschiedenen anderen
möglichkeiten wieder zu einer
normalisierung kommen und dass die
kinder dann auch in der schule sein
können dass es entscheidend
[Musik]